you love a dog look I love a dog walk
yeah I'm always aware dogging away oh
[Music]
we're on deck I'm on it's good to get
that and this is that was North versus
south for lad five all right ready for
the first one
have you seen this before you know what
yeah yeah I've seen there's two dishes
in there and then we pick north myself
it's good you'll love it got it it's
like a bush took a tram it is the
testicle right okay
right oh yes right Rusty's well I've
seen Brown so now we're happy because it
wouldn't be North versus South that was
it was for Greg I'm exhausted room
that's romantic
hold on hang on it's a big Hospital
it's a real boy like a real one I mean
like a a proper some meats here all
rather as a vegan do you know the story
behind the crust yes I do
come on so the story around the
Christmas the miners used to take these
down the mines so actually a proper
crushed which should be so now you eat
in the nude or the coastal way to grab
on to it yeah
so they had their dirty hands on the
cross yeah then they eat the body of the
pasty Roger said oh oh you said that I
switched off wow I like that a lot and
as Asador need a bit of typical a trip
with no need a little bit you've heard
to catch up dear my hand okay no cleaner
clearly I don't want your end not after
last that har very frumpy that's
delicious Nicole Michael Northwinds
totally would you last good okay now -
okay yeah Kendal mint cake versus
Cornish ice cream hold on it's not ice
cream
it's Eton Mess how versus it's a mess
it's
do you know the story about Kendal mint
kids anything new - no it's people take
them when they're hiking because it's
very high in calories so if you are ever
lost it's good snack knowledge guys
mention of pleasure it's okay is this is
this supposed to be like that or is it
it's gonna get it's gone very clear for
you don't you might have no running in
there is tiny tiny tiny pieces in the
round I mean I mean I thought it has to
call let's go for that I mean if I was
dog walking and I got lost you love a
dog I love a dog walk yeah look it'll
sip it don't blow it away a dog in a way
he's a big love a bit of dog in there
eat it everywhere before we before we
love ready oh is that a scotch pie apple
pie pies come on it was a porcupine fact
I love everything about the jelly [ __ ]
yeah why you feel like you've eaten eyes
and I mean that that to me is just a
lovely afternoon that you know I've just
got back it with dog in god I've got a
pork pie on the gore wonderful wonderful
kind of interest you and a little bit of
nonsense
smashed avocado ah on visit on sourdough
I don't mind I'm a corridor what I do
have an issue with is sourdough bread
why do you have an issue of sourdough
bread cause it's just hard
oh yeah poor part of me
North wind's yes
he's put in now it's very Georgie people
in so it's actually made of like split
season season and you put on a study
with ham and you have a harm
and feed for the sandwich and it's the
bomb
what slap versus gentleman's relish so
I've just gotten relic somebody so I've
never had gentleman's relish people Yeah
Yeah right
says here it's delicious on tourists
it's like a patty then I don't know oh
yeah burgers is as well
oh that's nice leave some bread you got
any bread done what are you little bit
of bread this little bit sour harmon
sourdough no I keep cutie bread Eileen
like it I mean it says it's delicious on
hot toast ha ha nothing oh good lord
is so salty you sparingly it says
Mozilla Oh run
it's so salty so salty I don't like this
button well I will hover over John
Cazale
oh yes was it ever in any doubt king in
the north
so we were on deck and that was snack
wars full archival Cheers
don't worry Simon I've never actually
gone dog it in my life you've got no
worries that we'd like to go dog
you
[Music]